which political party you think
lost
uh during covet
well so i something that i'd like to say
is
i'm going to get cancelled for saying
this but um
i am going to get cancer saying this but
i think for a long time reality had a
liberal bias like it was the liberals
who were pushing equality for blacks it
was the liberals who were pushing
equality for gays things that we all now
agree are like commonsensical right like
that every human deserves to live in
dignity but i think over the last five
years
last three years the last two years and
certainly over covet with the school
lockdowns with the endless lockdowns
with the you know this oppression of the
working class i really think that
reality has sort of started to take on a
bit of a conservative bias like it does
seem to me that the right
increasingly on questions that matter
very much to the american people
like the right to have a say over their
children's education their children's
life
their right to bodily autonomy you know
their right to live in dignity um
they're right to the american dream a
lot of these things i think increasingly
you hear conservatives speaking to where
most americans are at and representing a
reality that the left has really sort of
left in the dust yeah
uh i agree i agree that it's and by the
way some of the folks that maybe are
listening to you that are more
your side politically are kind of
sitting there saying well you can't say
that because if we do you know
didn't you just see the stat that a
million people switch from democrat to
republican the story just came out two
weeks ago you're helping that even more
but i would say this
the political party that lost the
rinkovic they initially won it's kind of
like a basketball game when they come
and say you know the celtics are up 28
points in the first quarter
the celtics lost by 17 points to the
golden state warriors so the democrats
started off with a big lead in the first
half oh my god look at you
freaking republicans and then fourth
quarter came around
what the hell were these guys doing
it it unfortunately unfortunately
a part of covet was awesome
for america to see i'm not talking the
loss of loved ones any of that
i'm talking a part of covet was it
revealed
what the motive really was for the
people on the left big time it revealed
and what do you think that motive was
control i know what's right for you you
know last night a shout out to elena who
works here
uh
do you know where the concept of
buildback better came out of
the world economic forum yeah so the
world economic forum is the original
build back better if you ever do you
have the link to this of i'm going to
show this it's our friend klaus schwab
that was a scary girl yeah so i'm gonna
i'm gonna send this to you i want you to
pull this up and and uh just take a look
at this article on uh world economic
forum
and and look at what the date is okay
that's what's concerning when was uh
when was the election by the way when
was the election november of what year
okay so so i want you to look at this
article tyler pull this article up that
i just sent you
pull this article up and look at the
date it's kind of weird
i'm not i'm not uh
i think if you're watching this folks i
think you need to dig into this for your
own self and do a little bit of research
spend 30 minutes on this and play around
and see what you figure out and pat the
world for is it just a bunch of people
rich elites that are just gathering
talking about what what's good for us
and what's not good for us i know some
of them we're talking about how you
should know
the new world order that's what we
wanted to become okay so watch this what
is the date
uh july maybe a little bit smaller so
they see the logo at the top and they
know what the link is what's the logo at
the top if you can zoom in world
economics can they see it right there
zoom in a little bit on the local all
the way at the top of the website it
says world economic forum if you look at
the link it's the world economic forum
website dot org
look at the date
july 13 2020. oh my god i feel like i
need a tin foil hat
we must reinvent capitalism
and then
biden without even
holding anything back
comes and they call it the build back
back better
the pandemic has brought us the focus of
vulnerabilities in our systems and
institutions but it also offers us a
chance to shape a more resilient and
sustainable world here's how businesses
and policymakers can start building the
green and
future we need thanks to an ongoing
pandemic thanks to the ongoing penalty
the world is off balance and over money
so far for years to come
far from settling into a new normal we
should expect the kova 19 domino effect
triggering further disruptions positive
as well as negative over the decade
ahead
okay so if you keep going lower and
lower there's a part that they talk
about a few different things okay go
lower that's the part so right there the
world's largest shipping company is
setting up a research center to
decarbonize the industry the great reset
after kova 19 must put people first
four-way stakeholder capitalism can
create a more resilient post-covered
mana region
so i don't know you know like you think
about it from this standpoint imagine if
you know if uh 30 years from now
a person goes up and goes runs for
office
and their campaign is called make
america great again
30 years from now yeah okay i'm gonna be
73. what's the first thing we're going
to be thinking about you guys like that
you stole that what heard it already
make america great again was from a guy
named trump
you know what the billionaire yeah you
guys weren't with that guy yeah make
america great again so imagine if you
take a campaign
from somebody in germany on what his
campaign was and it's the identical
you're not even changing a little bit
grow back better you know
like
verbatim
we need to build back better to re-set
a true recovery from covenanting will
not be about putting things back
together the way they were we need to
build back better to reset
this is why so many people are writing a
book called the great
reset i think beck wrote a book i think
a couple other people just wrote a book
this is their model it's the great reset
you'll own nothing and be happy yeah and
and that's what it was so so i don't
know so for me during covet what it did
is we really figured out what your
motives were like okay cool that's what
your motive is no problem
the moment i know and you know someone's
motive like when a woman goes on a date
with a guy and he straight up says
look just kind of an ugly divorce
i have no desire to have a girlfriend
but if you want to have fun let's go to
my place have fun i'll come to your
place if you just want to have fun
so
guess what advantage you have now
now you know my what
motive
so you can decide what to do with that
motive so now you have to make a
decision that's what
you either are going to say
between us
let's go chill
i'm cool
okay
or you may say
yeah
i've actually been out of a relationship
for a couple years
and i was a bad one but i'm ready to get
into a relationship and i actually want
somebody that i can have a serious
relationship with i've had too many of
these tinder stuff the last couple years
i'm done i kind of want to have somebody
serious
now i know your motive our motives don't
match but you know mine and i know yours
great
the democrat the democrats uh some of
them on the left kept their motives now
we know their motives and it's a
beautiful thing
because it's very hard to go back this
is why a lot of people who were
democrats who were registered democrats
saying i'm sorry bro i'm not with that
dog
i'm i'm okay you're there i'm not with
you so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]